you know one day I had finally had
enough I couldn't take it anymore and so
I went and opened up my Bible and it was
in the morning and I was sober that
morning I hadn't been drinking or
nothing yet
and I opened it up and it was the part
where Jesus peace be upon him he
prostrated in the garden where he he
fell on his face and he was praying and
begging to the Creator to not take this
cup from him you know and so on and so
forth and I told myself I said you know
what it was like it hit me really
clearly I was like Jesus he fell on his
face he prostrated like the Muslims do
and I remembered a couple weeks before I
listened to the preacher because we
don't have any Muslims where I'm from I
had never met a single Muslim until this
point in my life and I'm 20 uh 26 years
old or so and he brings up randomly
Muslims one day because we're out you
know in the country and he's like you
know don't don't do like the Muslims do
and never humiliate yourself and put
your face on the ground he's like we're
Christians we get on our knees and we
ask God we don't put our face in the
dirt
and that was a couple weeks before and
so this that day when I had finally just
you know gave up and I was like you know
what God I don't know what the truth is
I've been looking in the Hindu
scriptures I've been looking at
Christianity throughout all these sex
and all this other stuff and uh I was
like I can't find it and when I opened
up and I saw Jesus prostrating there in
the Bible
said how dare he say humiliate because
you know even though I don't worship
Jesus he's my you know my role model
and he said humiliate I would understand
if he said humble yourself but he said
humiliating so I had this like feeling
of kind of rebellion like you know not
to Jesus or to God but to the pastor
I said how dare you so I was like you
know what I'm gonna do what Jesus did
I'm gonna put my head on the ground I'm
gonna ask God to guide me
and so I did and when it happened
everything was clear I can't explain it
to you Eddie except that there was no
doubt in my mind that God was one but we
call yakina had certainty and something
was telling me to follow Muhammad for
the rest of my life and so I told myself
if this was real you know I got up and I
said if this is real I got to find out
about it so I actually had a Quran on my
shelf this is one of the books I haven't
read and so I'm gonna actually read it
and as soon as I opened up the book
Eddie that first page I started reading
I could not stop crying you know I read
from Factory hat and then I would go to
a open up to another part and every
single word that I read even though it
was in English translation resonated
with me of the Quran foreign
I couldn't stop I would it was like a
hunger it was unsatiable I just I kept
reading and reading then I would go
online and watch YouTube videos like
what is this that I found I cannot
believe this who is this Prophet
Muhammad
peace be upon him
and I was just over the moon I was like
I found it I realized was worthy of
worship except for the uncreated creator
of the heavens and the Earth as soon as
the words left my mouth
Eddie I don't know how to describe it to
you everything like went went white like
I had this experience that like I was
just surrounded with with light and it
was like washing me from the inside out
and the prophet Muhammad he talks to us
about how whenever a person accepts
Islam that all of their sins are
completely forgiven from what they did
before but this was almost like a you
know a manifestation of that you know
had goosebumps in this euphoria that was
better than anything I'd ever drank or
taken or done before in my entire life
that feeling was better than the most
Blissful moment times like a million and
and I couldn't stop crying and it was
crazy everyone I mean I've been through
a lot of shahadas but everyone in the
whole audience all of the other brothers
and whatnot ever we're all crying
together and Camilla meki's crying and
I knew in my heart after I said the
testimony of Faith which is I testify
that there is no God worthy of worship
except for Allah be God the one true God
alone and I testify that Muhammad is the
messenger of God the ultimate statement
I ever made in my life and so you know I
live by that statement now if you uh I
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and you still have some questions about
Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you